since writing for the greenlight which
was in 2014 or 15 25 2015 okay
has your personal opinion wavered on
anything in the book that you were maybe
more dogmatic about and then since a new
film has come out or something's changed
you've actually changed your opinion on
it no I mean only in the sense that when
you're writing a book you know if it was
a blog or something else you can be a
little bit more like this is what's
working today and right now I wrote that
book and the new book I'm working on
also about distribution I focus on
principles not rules not gimmicks not
trends principles principles or I mean
think about like engineering for
instance we sent human beings to the
moon and return them to the earth with
as much computing power on board as a
for function calculator people were
using slide rulers at NASA to calculate
how are we going to land an object on
the moon so you think technology today
is going to you know send us to wherever
and all these other things the truth is
the principles that work in technology
today in an engineering level are
exactly the same as they were in the 60s
just different tools to get to the same
result
writing for the green lights the same
idea if you're trying to be a writer if
you're trying to build your career as a
writer there are certain tools that you
can have in your tool kit that are going
to propel you and there are others that
are just gonna hold you back
those goldmine genres that I wrote about
in that book are as true today as they
were in the 60s as they were in the 40s
as they will be 30 years from now you
know sharknado there's a great example
of a creature feature you see women in
peril thrillers all the time on TV you
see them all over the world action
movies with with aging stars have been
here from the beginning of the b-movie
as the second tier to a major one and
they're gonna continue no matter what
they were big in the 80s and the 90s
because of video rentals and now they're
big today because of VOD opportunities
it's these are just core value content
pieces that every company looks for in
one capacity or another
so in truth it's as true when it was
written a few years ago as it will be in
the future - and because it's a book
really focused on the stuff that's going
to stick around
you